The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN TSITSIKLIS: OK.
We can start.
Good morning.
So we're going to start
now a new unit.
For the next couple of lectures,
we will be talking
about continuous random
variables.
So this is new material
which is not going
to be in the quiz.
You are going to have a long
break next week without any
lecture, just a quiz and
recitation and tutorial.
So what's going to happen
in this new unit?
Basically, we want to do
everything that we did for
discrete random variables,
reintroduce the same sort of
concepts but see how they apply
and how they need to be
modified in order to talk about
random variables that
take continuous values.
At some level, it's
all the same.
At some level, it's quite a bit
harder because when things
are continuous, calculus
comes in.
So the calculations that you
have to do on the side
sometimes need a little
bit more thinking.
In terms of new concepts,
there's not going to be a
whole lot today, some analogs
of things we have done.
We're going to introduce the
concept of cumulative
distribution functions, which
allows us to deal with
discrete and continuous
random variables, all
of them in one shot.
And finally, introduce a famous
kind of continuous
random variable, the normal
random variable.
OK, so what's the story?
Continuous random variables are
random variables that take
values over the continuum.
So the numerical value of the
random variable can be any
real number.
They don't take values just
in a discrete set.
So we have our sample space.
The experiment happens.
We get some omega, a sample
point in the sample space.
And once that point is
determined, it determines the
numerical value of the
random variable.
Remember, random variables are
functions on the sample space.
You pick a sample point.
This determines the numerical
value of the random variable.
So that numerical value is going
to be some real number
on that line.
Now we want to say something
about the distribution of the
random variable.
We want to say which values are
more likely than others to
occur in a certain sense.
For example, you may be
interested in a particular
event, the event that the random
variable takes values
in the interval from a to b.
And we want to say something
about the
probability of that event.
In principle, how
is this done?
You go back to the sample space,
and you find all those
outcomes for which the value of
the random variable happens
to be in that interval.
The probability that the random
variable falls here is
the same as the probability of
all outcomes that make the
random variable to
fall in there.
So in principle, you can work on
the original sample space,
find the probability of this
event, and you would be done.
But similar to what happened in
chapter 2, we want to kind
of push the sample space in the
background and just work
directly on the real
axis and talk about
probabilities up here.
So we want now a way to specify
probabilities, how
they are bunched together, or
arranged, along the real line.
So what did we do for discrete
random variables?
We introduced PMFs, probability
mass functions.
And the way that we described
the random variable was by
saying this point has so much
mass on top of it, that point
has so much mass on top
of it, and so on.
And so we assigned a total
amount of 1 unit of
probability.
We assigned it to different
masses, which we put at
different points on
the real axis.
So that's what you do if
somebody gives you a pound of
discrete stuff, a pound of
mass in little chunks.
And you place those chunks
at a few points.
Now, in the continuous case,
this total unit of probability
mass does not sit just on
discrete points but is spread
all over the real axis.
So now we're going to have a
unit of mass that spreads on
top of the real axis.
How do we describe masses that
are continuously spread?
The way we describe them is
by specifying densities.
That is, how thick is the mass
that's sitting here?
How dense is the mass that's
sitting there?
So that's exactly what
we're going to do.
We're going to introduce the
concept of a probability
density function that tells us
how probabilities accumulate
at different parts
of the real axis.
So here's an example or a
picture of a possible
probability density function.
What does that density function
kind of convey
intuitively?
Well, that these x's
are relatively
less likely to occur.
Those x's are somewhat more
likely to occur because the
density is higher.
Now, for a more formal
definition, we're going to say
that a random variable X is said
to be continuous if it
can be described by a
density function in
the following sense.
We have a density function.
And we calculate probabilities
of falling inside an interval
by finding the area under
the curve that sits
on top of that interval.
So that's sort of the defining
relation for
continuous random variables.
It's an implicit definition.
And it tells us a random
variable is continuous if we
can calculate probabilities
this way.
So the probability of falling
in this interval is the area
under this curve.
Mathematically, it's the
integral of the density over
this particular interval.
If the density happens to be
constant over that interval,
the area under the curve would
be the length of the interval
times the height of
the density, which
sort of makes sense.
Now, because the density is not
constant but it kind of
moves around, what you need is
to write down an integral.
Now, this formula is very much
analogous to what you would do
for discrete random variables.
For a discrete random variable,
how do you calculate
this probability?
You look at all x's
in this interval.
And you add the probability mass
function over that range.
So just for comparison, this
would be the formula for the
discrete case--
the sum over all x's in the
interval from a to b over the
probability mass function.
And there is a syntactic analogy
that's happening here
and which will be a persistent
theme when we deal with
continuous random variables.
Sums get replaced
by integrals.
In the discrete case, you add.
In the continuous case,
you integrate.
Mass functions get replaced
by density functions.
So you can take pretty much any
formula from the discrete
case and translate it to a
continuous analog of that
formula, as we're
going to see.
OK.
So let's take this
now as our model.
What is the probability that
the random variable takes a
specific value if we have a
continuous random variable?
Well, this would be the case.
It's a case of a trivial
interval, where the two end
points coincide.
So it would be the integral
from a to itself.
So you're integrating just
over a single point.
Now, when you integrate over
a single point, the
integral is just 0.
The area under the curve, if
you're only looking at a
single point, it's 0.
So big property of continuous
random variables is that any
individual point has
0 probability.
In particular, when you look at
the value of the density,
the density does not tell you
the probability of that point.
The point itself has
0 probability.
So the density tells you
something a little different.
We are going to see shortly
what that is.
Before we get there,
can the density be
an arbitrary function?
Almost, but not quite.
There are two things
that we want.
First, since densities
are used to calculate
probabilities, and since
probabilities must be
non-negative, the density should
also be non-negative.
Otherwise you would be getting
negative probabilities, which
is not a good thing.
So that's a basic property
that any density function
should obey.
The second property that we
need is that the overall
probability of the entire real
line should be equal to 1.
So if you ask me, what is the
probability that x falls
between minus infinity and plus
infinity, well, we are
sure that x is going to
fall in that range.
So the probability of that
event should be 1.
So the probability of being
between minus infinity and
plus infinity should be 1, which
means that the integral
from minus infinity to plus
infinity should be 1.
So that just tells us that
there's 1 unit of total
probability that's being
spread over our space.
Now, what's the best way to
think intuitively about what
the density function does?
The interpretation that I find
most natural and easy to
convey the meaning of a
density is to look at
probabilities of small
intervals.
So let us take an x somewhere
here and then x plus delta
just next to it.
So delta is a small number.
And let's look at the
probability of the event that
we get a value in that range.
For continuous random variables,
the way we find the
probability of falling in that
range is by integrating the
density over that range.
So we're drawing this picture.
And we want to take the
area under this curve.
Now, what happens if delta
is a fairly small number?
If delta is pretty small, our
density is not going to change
much over that range.
So you can pretend that
the density is
approximately constant.
And so to find the area under
the curve, you just take the
base times the height.
And it doesn't matter where
exactly you take the height in
that interval, because the
density doesn't change very
much over that interval.
And so the integral becomes just
base times the height.
So for small intervals, the
probability of a small
interval is approximately
the density times delta.
So densities essentially
give us
probabilities of small intervals.
And if you want to think about
it a little differently, you
can take that delta from
here and send it to
the denominator there.
And what this tells you
is that the density is
probability per unit length for
intervals of small length.
So the units of density are
probability per unit length.
Densities are not
probabilities.
They are rates at which
probabilities accumulate,
probabilities per unit length.
And since densities are not
probabilities, they don't have
to be less than 1.
Ordinary probabilities always
must be less than 1.
But density is a different
kind of thing.
It can get pretty big
in some places.
It can even sort of blow
up in some places.
As long as the total area under
the curve is 1, other
than that, the curve can do
anything that it wants.
Now, the density prescribes
for us the
probability of intervals.
Sometimes we may want to find
the probability of more
general sets.
How would we do that?
Well, for nice sets, you will
just integrate the density
over that nice set.
I'm not quite defining
what "nice" means.
That's a pretty technical
topic in the theory of
probability.
But for our purposes, usually we
will take b to be something
like a union of intervals.
So how do you find the
probability of falling in the
union of two intervals?
Well, you find the probability
of falling in that interval
plus the probability of falling
in that interval.
So it's the integral over this
interval plus the integral
over that interval.
And you think of this as just
integrating over the union of
the two intervals.
So once you can calculate
probabilities of intervals,
then usually you are in
business, and you can
calculate anything else
you might want.
So the probability density
function is a complete
description of any statistical
information we might be
interested in for a continuous
random variable.
OK.
So now we can start walking
through the concepts and the
definitions that we have for
discrete random variables and
translate them to the
continuous case.
The first big concept is the
concept of the expectation.
One can start with a
mathematical definition.
And here we put down
a definition by
just translating notation.
Wherever we have a sum in
the discrete case, we
now write an integral.
And wherever we had the
probability mass function, we
now throw in the probability
density function.
This formula--
you may have seen it in
freshman physics--
basically, it again gives you
the center of gravity of the
picture that you have when
you have the density.
It's the center of gravity of
the object sitting underneath
the probability density
function.
So that the interpretation
still applies.
It's also true that our
conceptual interpretation of
what an expectation means is
also valid in this case.
That is, if you repeat an
experiment a zillion times,
each time drawing an independent
sample of your
random variable x, in the long
run, the average that you are
going to get should be
the expectation.
One can reason in a hand-waving
way, sort of
intuitively, the way we did it
for the case of discrete
random variables.
But this is also a theorem
of some sort.
It's a limit theorem that we're
going to visit later on
in this class.
Having defined the expectation
and having claimed that the
interpretation of the
expectation is that same as
before, then we can start taking
just any formula you've
seen before and just
translate it.
So for example, to find the
expected value of a function
of a continuous random variable,
you do not have to
find the PDF or PMF of g(X).
You can just work directly with
the original distribution
of the random variable
capital X.
And this formula is the same
as for the discrete case.
Sums get replaced
by integrals.
And PMFs get replaced by PDFs.
And in particular, the variance
of a random variable
is defined again the same way.
The variance is the expected
value, the average of the
distance of X from the mean
and then squared.
So it's the expected value for
a random variable that takes
these numerical values.
And same formula as before,
integral and F instead of
summation, and the P.
And the formulas that we have
derived or formulas that you
have seen for the discrete case,
they all go through the
continuous case.
So for example, the useful
relation for variances, which
is this one, remains true.
All right.
So time for an example.
The most simple example of a
continuous random variable
that there is, is the so-called
uniform random variable.
So the uniform random variable
is described by a density
which is 0 except over
an interval.
And over that interval,
it is constant.
What is it meant to convey?
It's trying to convey the idea
that all x's in this range are
equally likely.
Well, that doesn't
say very much.
Any individual x has
0 probability.
So it's conveying a little
more than that.
What it is saying is that if I
take an interval of a given
length delta, and I take another
interval of the same
length, delta, under the uniform
distribution, these
two intervals are going to have
the same probability.
So being uniform means that
intervals of same length have
the same probability.
So no interval is more likely
than any other to occur.
And in that sense, it conveys
the idea of sort of complete
randomness.
Any little interval in our range
is equally likely as any
other little interval.
All right.
So what's the formula
for this density?
I only told you the range.
What's the height?
Well, the area under the density
must be equal to 1.
Total probability
is equal to 1.
And so the height, inescapably,
is going to be 1
over (b minus a).
That's the height that makes
the density integrate to 1.
So that's the formula.
And if you don't want to lose
one point in your exam, you
have to say that it's
also 0, otherwise.
OK.
All right?
That's sort of the
complete answer.
How about the expected value
of this random variable?
OK.
You can find the expected value
in two different ways.
One is to start with
the definition.
And so you integrate
over the range of
interest times the density.
And you figure out what that
integral is going to be.
Or you can be a little
more clever.
Since the center-of-gravity
interpretation is still true,
it must be the center of gravity
of this picture.
And the center of gravity is,
of course, the midpoint.
Whenever you have symmetry,
the mean is always the
midpoint of the diagram that
gives you the PDF.
OK.
So that's the expected
value of X.
Finally, regarding the variance,
well, there you will
have to do a little
bit of calculus.
We can write down
the definition.
So it's an integral
instead of a sum.
A typical value of the random
variable minus the expected
value, squared, times
the density.
And we integrate.
You do this integral, and you
find it's (b minus a) squared
over that number, which
happens to be 12.
Maybe more interesting is the
standard deviation itself.
And you see that the standard
deviation is proportional to
the width of that interval.
This agrees with our intuition,
that the standard
deviation is meant to capture a
sense of how spread out our
distribution is.
And the standard deviation has
the same units as the random
variable itself.
So it's sort of good to-- you
can interpret it in a
reasonable way based
on that picture.
OK, yes.
Now, let's go up one level and
think about the following.
So we have formulas for the
discrete case, formulas for
the continuous case.
So you can write them
side by side.
One has sums, the other
has integrals.
Suppose you want to make an
argument and say that
something is true for every
random variable.
You would essentially need to
do two separate proofs, for
discrete and for continuous.
Is there some way of dealing
with random variables just one
at a time, in one shot, using
a sort of uniform notation?
Is there a unifying concept?
Luckily, there is one.
It's the notion of the
cumulative distribution
function of a random variable.
And it's a concept that applies
equally well to
discrete and continuous
random variables.
So it's an object that we can
use to describe distributions
in both cases, using just
one piece of notation.
So what's the definition?
It's the probability that the
random variable takes values
less than a certain
number little x.
So you go to the diagram, and
you see what's the probability
that I'm falling to
the left of this.
And you specify those
probabilities for all x's.
In the continuous case, you
calculate those probabilities
using the integral formula.
So you integrate from
here up to x.
In the discrete case, to find
the probability to the left of
some point, you go here, and
you add probabilities again
from the left.
So the way that the cumulative
distribution function is
calculated is a little different
in the continuous
and discrete case.
In one case you integrate.
In the other, you sum.
But leaving aside how it's being
calculated, what the
concept is, it's the same
concept in both cases.
So let's see what the shape of
the cumulative distribution
function would be in
the two cases.
So here what we want is to
record for every little x the
probability of falling
to the left of x.
So let's start here.
Probability of falling to
the left of here is 0--
0, 0, 0.
Once we get here and we start
moving to the right, the
probability of falling to the
left of here is the area of
this little rectangle.
And the area of that little
rectangle increases linearly
as I keep moving.
So accordingly, the CDF
increases linearly until I get
to that point.
At that point, what's
the value of my CDF?
1.
I have accumulated all the
probability there is.
I have integrated it.
This total area has
to be equal to 1.
So it reaches 1, and then
there's no more probability to
be accumulated.
It just stays at 1.
So the value here
is equal to 1.
OK.
How would you find the density
if somebody gave you the CDF?
The CDF is the integral
of the density.
Therefore, the density is the
derivative of the CDF.
So you look at this picture
and take the derivative.
Derivative is 0 here, 0 here.
And it's a constant
up there, which
corresponds to that constant.
So more generally, and an
important thing to know, is
that the derivative of the CDF
is equal to the density--
almost, with a little
bit of an exception.
What's the exception?
At those places where the CDF
does not have a derivative--
here where it has a corner--
the derivative is undefined.
And in some sense, the
density is also
ambiguous at that point.
Is my density at the endpoint,
is it 0 or is it 1?
It doesn't really matter.
If you change the density at
just a single point, it's not
going to affect the
value of any
integral you ever calculate.
So the value of the density at
the endpoint, you can leave it
as being ambiguous, or
you can specify it.
It doesn't matter.
So at all places where the
CDF has a derivative,
this will be true.
At those places where you have
corners, which do show up
sometimes, well, you
don't really care.
How about the discrete case?
In the discrete case, the CDF
has a more peculiar shape.
So let's do the calculation.
We want to find the
probability of b
to the left of here.
That probability is 0, 0, 0.
Once we cross that point, the
probability of being to the
left of here is 1/6.
So as soon as we cross the
point 1, we get the
probability of 1/6, which means
that the size of the
jump that we have here is 1/6.
Now, question.
At this point 1, which is the
correct value of the CDF?
Is it 0, or is it 1/6?
It's 1/6 because--
you need to look carefully
at the definitions, the
probability of x being less
than or equal to little x.
If I take little x to be 1,
it's the probability that
capital X is less than
or equal to 1.
So it includes the event
that x is equal to 1.
So it includes this
probability here.
So at jump points, the correct
value of the CDF is going to
be this one.
And now as I trace, x is
going to the right.
As soon as I cross this point,
I have added another 3/6
probability.
So that 3/6 causes a
jump to the CDF.
And that determines
the new value.
And finally, once I cross
the last point, I get
another jump of 2/6.
A general moral from these two
examples and these pictures.
CDFs are well defined
in both cases.
For the case of continuous
random variables, the CDF will
be a continuous function.
It starts from 0.
It eventually goes to 1
and goes smoothly--
well, continuously from smaller
to higher values.
It can only go up.
It cannot go down since we're
accumulating more and more
probability as we are
going to the right.
In the discrete case, again
it starts from 0,
and it goes to 1.
But it does it in a
staircase manner.
And you get a jump at each place
where the PMF assigns a
positive mass.
So jumps in the CDF are
associated with point masses
in our distribution.
In the continuous case, we don't
have any point masses,
so we do not have any
jumps either.
Now, besides saving
us notation--
we don't have to deal
with discrete
and continuous twice--
CDFs give us actually a little
more flexibility.
Not all random variables are
continuous or discrete.
You can cook up random variables
that are kind of
neither or a mixture
of the two.
An example would be, let's
say you play a game.
And with a certain probability,
you get a certain
number of dollars
in your hands.
So you flip a coin.
And with probability 1/2, you
get a reward of 1/2 dollars.
are led to a dark room where
you spin a wheel of fortune.
And that wheel of fortune gives
you a random reward
between 0 and 1.
So any of these outcomes
is possible.
And the amount that you're
going to get,
let's say, is uniform.
So you flip a coin.
And depending on the outcome of
the coin, either you get a
certain value or you get a
value that ranges over a
continuous interval.
So what kind of random
variable is it?
Is it continuous?
Well, continuous random
variables assign 0 probability
to individual points.
Is it the case here?
No, because you have positive
probability of
obtaining 1/2 dollar.
So our random variable
is not continuous.
Is it discrete?
It's not discrete, because our
random variable can take
values also over a
continuous range.
So we call such a random
variable a
mixed random variable.
If you were to draw its
distribution very loosely,
probably you would want to draw
a picture like this one,
which kind of conveys the
idea of what's going on.
So just think of this as a
drawing of masses that are
sitting over a table.
We place an object that weighs
half a pound, but it's an
object that takes zero space.
So half a pound is just sitting
on top of that point.
And we take another half-pound
of probability and spread it
uniformly over that interval.
So this is like a piece that
comes from mass functions.
And that's a piece that looks
more like a density function.
And we just throw them together
in the picture.
I'm not trying to associate
any formal
meaning with this picture.
It's just a schematic of how
probabilities are distributed,
help us visualize
what's going on.
Now, if you have taken classes
on systems and all of that,
you may have seen the concept
of an impulse function.
And you my start saying that,
oh, I should treat this
mathematically as a so-called
impulse function.
But we do not need this for our
purposes in this class.
Just think of this as a nice
picture that conveys what's
going on in this particular
case.
So now, what would the CDF
look like in this case?
The CDF is always well defined,
no matter what kind
of random variable you have.
So the fact that it's not
continuous, it's not discrete
shouldn't be a problem as
long as we can calculate
probabilities of this kind.
So the probability of falling
to the left here is 0.
Once I start crossing there, the
probability of falling to
the left of a point increases
linearly with
how far I have gone.
So we get this linear
increase.
But as soon as I cross that
point, I accumulate another
1/2 unit of probability
instantly.
And once I accumulate that 1/2
unit, it means that my CDF is
going to have a jump of 1/2.
And then afterwards, I still
keep accumulating probability
at a fixed rate, the rate
being the density.
And I keep accumulating, again,
at a linear rate until
I settle to 1.
So this is a CDF that has
certain pieces where it
increases continuously.
And that corresponds to the
continuous part of our
randomize variable.
And it also has some places
where it has discrete jumps.
And those district jumps
correspond to places in which
we have placed a
positive mass.
And by the--
OK, yeah.
So this little 0 shouldn't
be there.
So let's cross it out.
All right.
So finally, we're going to take
the remaining time and
introduce our new friend.
It's going to be the Gaussian
or normal distribution.
So it's the most important
distribution there is in all
of probability theory.
It's plays a very
central role.
It shows up all over
the place.
We'll see later in the
class in more detail
why it shows up.
But the quick preview
is the following.
If you have a phenomenon in
which you measure a certain
quantity, but that quantity is
made up of lots and lots of
random contributions--
so your random variable is
actually the sum of lots and
lots of independent little
random variables--
then invariability, no matter
what kind of distribution the
little random variables have,
their sum will turn out to
have approximately a normal
distribution.
So this makes the normal
distribution to arise very
naturally in lots and
lots of contexts.
Whenever you have noise that's
comprised of lots of different
independent pieces of noise,
then the end result will be a
random variable that's normal.
So we are going to come back
to that topic later.
But that's the preview comment,
basically to argue
that it's an important one.
OK.
And there's a special case.
If you are dealing with a
binomial distribution, which
is the sum of lots of Bernoulli
random variables,
again you would expect that
the binomial would start
looking like a normal if you
have many, many-- a large
number of point fields.
All right.
So what's the math
involved here?
Let's parse the formula for
the density of the normal.
What we start with is the
function X squared over 2.
And if you are to plot X
squared over 2, it's a
parabola, and it has
this shape --
X squared over 2.
Then what do we do?
We take the negative exponential
of this.
So when X squared over
2 is 0, then negative
exponential is 1.
When X squared over 2 increases,
the negative
exponential of that falls off,
and it falls off pretty fast.
So as this goes up, the
formula for the
density goes down.
And because exponentials are
pretty strong in how quickly
they fall off, this means that
the tails of this distribution
actually do go down
pretty fast.
OK.
So that explains the shape
of the normal PDF.
How about this factor 1
over square root 2 pi?
Where does this come from?
Well, the integral has
to be equal to 1.
So you have to go and do your
calculus exercise and find the
integral of this the minus X
squared over 2 function and
then figure out, what constant
do I need to put in front so
that the integral
is equal to 1?
How do you evaluate
that integral?
Either you go to Mathematica
or Wolfram's Alpha or
whatever, and it tells
you what it is.
Or it's a very beautiful
calculus exercise that you may
have seen at some point.
You throw in another exponential
of this kind, you
bring in polar coordinates, and
somehow the answer comes
beautifully out there.
But in any case, this is the
constant that you need to make
it integrate to 1 and to be
a legitimate density.
We call this the standard
normal.
And for the standard normal,
what is the expected value?
Well, the symmetry, so
it's equal to 0.
What is the variance?
Well, here there's
no shortcut.
You have to do another
calculus exercise.
And you find that the variance
is equal to 1.
OK.
So this is a normal that's
centered around 0.
How about other types of normals
that are centered at
different places?
So we can do the same
kind of thing.
Instead of centering it at 0,
we can take some place where
we want to center it, write down
a quadratic such as (X
minus mu) squared, and then
take the negative
exponential of that.
And that gives us a normal
density that's centered at mu.
Now, I may wish to control
the width of my density.
To control the width of my
density, equivalently I can
control the width
of my parabola.
If my parabola is narrower, if
my parabola looks like this,
what's going to happen
to the density?
It's going to fall
off much faster.
OK.
How do I make my parabola
narrower or wider?
I do it by putting in a
constant down here.
So by putting a sigma here, this
stretches or widens my
parabola by a factor of sigma.
Let's see.
Which way does it go?
If sigma is very small,
this is a big number.
My parabola goes up quickly,
which means my normal falls
off very fast.
So small sigma corresponds
to a narrower density.
And so it, therefore, should be
intuitive that the standard
deviation is proportional
to sigma.
Because that's the amount
by which you
are scaling the picture.
And indeed, the standard
deviation is sigma.
And so the variance
is sigma squared.
So all that we have done here
to create a general normal
with a given mean and variance
is to take this picture, shift
it in space so that the mean
sits at mu instead of 0, and
then scale it by a
factor of sigma.
This gives us a normal
with a given
mean and a given variance.
And the formula for
it is this one.
All right.
Now, normal random variables
have some wonderful
properties.
And one of them is that they
behave nicely when you take
linear functions of them.
So let's fix some constants
a and b, suppose that X is
normal, and look at this
linear function Y.
What is the expected
value of Y?
Here we don't need
anything special.
We know that the expected value
of a linear function is
the linear function of
the expectation.
So the expected value is this.
How about the variance?
We know that the variance of a
linear function doesn't care
about the constant term.
But the variance gets multiplied
by a squared.
So we get these variance, where
sigma squared is the
variance of the original
normal.
So have we used so far the
property that X is normal?
No, we haven't.
This calculation here is true
in general when you take a
linear function of a
random variable.
But if X is normal, we get the
other additional fact that Y
is also going to be normal.
So that's the nontrivial
part of the fact that
I'm claiming here.
So linear functions of normal
random variables are
themselves normal.
How do we convince ourselves
about it?
OK.
It's something that we will do
formerly in about two or three
lectures from today.
So we're going to prove it.
But if you think about it
intuitively, normal means this
particular bell-shaped curve.
And that bell-shaped curve could
be sitting anywhere and
could be scaled in any way.
So you start with a
bell-shaped curve.
If you take X, which is bell
shaped, and you multiply it by
a constant, what does that do?
Multiplying by a constant is
just like scaling the axis or
changing the units with which
you're measuring it.
So it will take a bell shape
and spread it or narrow it.
But it will still
be a bell shape.
And then when you add the
constant, you just take that
bell and move it elsewhere.
So under linear transformations,
bell shapes
will remain bell shapes, just
sitting at a different place
and with a different width.
And that sort of the intuition
of why normals remain normals
under this kind of
transformation.
So why is this useful?
Well, OK.
We have a formula
for the density.
But usually we want to calculate
probabilities.
How will you calculate
probabilities?
If I ask you, what's the
probability that the normal is
less than 3, how
do you find it?
You need to integrate the
density from minus
infinity up to 3.
Unfortunately, the integral of
the expression that shows up
that you would have to
calculate, an integral of this
kind from, let's say, minus
infinity to some number, is
something that's not known
in closed form.
So if you're looking for a
closed-form formula for this--
X bar--
if you're looking for a
closed-form formula that gives
you the value of this integral
as a function of X bar, you're
not going to find it.
So what can we do?
Well, since it's a useful
integral, we can
just tabulate it.
Calculate it once and for all,
for all values of X bar up to
some precision, and have
that table, and use it.
That's what one does.
OK, but now there is a catch.
Are we going to write down a
table for every conceivable
type of normal distribution--
that is, for every possible
mean and every variance?
I guess that would be
a pretty long table.
You don't want to do that.
Fortunately, it's enough to
have a table with the
numerical values only for
the standard normal.
And once you have those, you can
use them in a clever way
to calculate probabilities for
the more general case.
So let's see how this is done.
So our starting point is that
someone has graciously
calculated for us the values
of the CDF, the cumulative
distribution function, that is
the probability of falling
below a certain point for
the standard normal
and at various places.
How do we read this table?
The probability that X is
less than, let's say,
0.63 is this number.
This number, 0.7357, is the
probability that the standard
normal is below 0.63.
So the table refers to
the standard normal.
But someone, let's say, gives
us some other numbers and
tells us we're dealing with a
normal with a certain mean and
a certain variance.
And we want to calculate the
probability that the value of
that random variable is less
than or equal to 3.
How are we going to do it?
Well, there's a standard trick,
which is so-called
standardizing a random
variable.
Standardizing a random variable
stands for the following.
You look at the random
variable, and you
subtract the mean.
This makes it a random
variable with 0 mean.
And then if I divide by the
standard deviation, what
happens to the variance of
this random variable?
Dividing by a number divides the
variance by sigma squared.
The original variance of
X was sigma squared.
So when I divide by sigma, I
end up with unit variance.
So after I do this
transformation, I get a random
variable that has 0 mean
and unit variance.
It is also normal.
Why is its normal?
Because this expression is a
linear function of the X that
I started with.
It's a linear function of a
normal random variable.
Therefore, it is normal.
And it is a standard normal.
So by taking a general normal
random variable and doing this
standardization, you end up
with a standard normal to
which you can then
apply the table.
Sometimes one calls this
the normalized score.
If you're thinking about test
results, how would you
interpret this number?
It tells you how many standard
deviations are you
away from the mean.
This is how much you are
And you count it in terms
of how many standard
deviations it is.
So this number being equal to 3
tells you that X happens to
be 3 standard deviations
above the mean.
And I guess if you're looking
at your quiz scores, very
often that's the kind of number
that you think about.
So it's a useful quantity.
But it's also useful for doing
the calculation we're now
going to do.
So suppose that X has a mean of
2 and a variance of 16, so
a standard deviation of 4.
And we're going to calculate the
probability of this event.
This event is described in terms
of this X that has ugly
means and variances.
But we can take this event
and rewrite it as
an equivalent event.
X less than 3 is this same as
X minus 2 being less than 3
minus 2, which is the same as
this ratio being less than
that ratio.
So I'm subtracting from both
sides of the inequality the
mean and then dividing by
the standard deviation.
This event is the same
as that event.
Why do we like this
better than that?
We like it because this is the
standardized, or normalized,
version of X. We know that
this is standard normal.
And so we're asking the
question, what's the
probability that the standard
normal is less than this
number, which is 1/4?
So that's the key property, that
this is normal (0, 1).
And so we can look up now with
the table and ask for the
probability that the standard
normal random variable
is less than 0.25.
Where is that going to be?
0.2, 0.25, it's here.
So the answer is 0.987.
So I guess this is just a drill
that you could learn in
high school.
You didn't have to come here
to learn about it.
But it's a drill that's very
useful when we will be
calculating normal probabilities
all the time.
So make sure you know how to
use the table and how to
massage a general normal
random variable into a
standard normal random
variable.
OK.
So just one more minute to look
at the big picture and
take stock of what we
have done so far
and where we're going.
Chapter 2 was this part of the
picture, where we dealt with
discrete random variables.
And this time, today, we
started talking about
continuous random variables.
And we introduced the density
function, which is the analog
of the probability
mass function.
We have the concepts
of expectation and
variance and CDF.
And this kind of notation
applies to both discrete and
continuous cases.
They are calculated the same way
in both cases except that
in the continuous case,
you use sums.
In the discrete case,
you use integrals.
So on that side, you
have integrals.
In this case, you have sums.
In this case, you always have
Fs in your formulas.
Ps in your formulas.
So what's there that's left
for us to do is to look at
these two concepts, joint
probability mass functions and
conditional mass functions, and
figure out what would be
the equivalent concepts on
the continuous side.
So we will need some notion of
a joint density when we're
dealing with multiple
random variables.
And we will also need the
concept of conditional
density, again for the case of
continuous random variables.
The intuition and the meaning
of these objects is going to
be exactly the same as here,
only a little subtler because
densities are not
probabilities.
They're rates at which
probabilities accumulate.
So that adds a little bit of
potential confusion here,
which, hopefully, we will fully
resolve in the next
couple of sections.
All right.
Thank you.